CHICAGO.
♪
>> Bret: THIS IS ANOTHER FOX
NEWS ALERT.
BREAKING NEWS ABOUT U.S.
IMMIGRATION POLICY, HOW THE
PRESIDENT INTENDS TO ENFORCE
IT AND HOW MIGRANTS FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA ARE TRYING
TO GET AROUND IT WE HAVE FOX
TEAM COVERAGE ON THIS
BREAKING NEWS.
WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE IN
TIJUANA, MEXICO WHERE
MIGRANTS HAVE FLOODED THE
BORDER TOWN ANGERING MANY
WHO LIVE THERE NEW DETAILS
ABOUT THAT CARAVAN, TOO.
WE START OFF WITH NEWS
CORRESPONDENT JENNIFER
GRIFFIN AT THE PENTAGON
ABOUT TROOP LEVELS ALONG THE
BORDER.
GOOD EVENING, JENNIFER.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH
POLITICO JEFFREY BUCHANAN,
THE ARMY GENERAL OVERSEEING
THE DEPLOYMENT OF 58 U.S.
TROOPS TO THE BORDER SAID
SOME OF THOSE TROOPS COULD
START COMING HOME THIS WEEK
AND THAT ALL OF THE TROOPS
WILL LIKELY BE HOME BY
CHRISTMAS.
EVEN AS A CARAVAN OF
MIGRANTS CONTINUES TO MAKE
ITS WAY TO TIJUANA.
U.S. CUSTOMS OFFICERS WERE
FORCED TO CLOSE A BORDER
CROSSING NEAR TIJUANA AS A
RESULT.
LIEUTENANT GENERAL BUCHANAN
ALSO CONFIRMED REPORTS THAT
FOX NEWS AND OTHERS HAVE
REPORTED THAT THE PENTAGON
PUSHED BACK ON A REQUEST BY
DHS FOR ARMED U.S. TROOPS TO
BE IN CONTACT WITH MIGRANTS
CITING LEGAL AUTHORITY.
SOME OF THE ENGINEERING
TROOPS ARE NO LONGER NEEDED
BECAUSE THEIR JOB IS DONE.
SO SOME MAY BE ABLE TO START
LEAVING THIS WEEK.
QUOTE OUR END DATE RIGHT NOW
IS DECEMBER 15TH.
AND I HAVE NO INDICATION
FROM ANYBODY THAT WE'LL GO
BEYOND THAT.
BUCHANON TOLD POLITICO.
HOWEVER, SOME OF THE TROOPS
SENT TO TEXAS COULD BE SENT
TO HELP IN OTHER SPOTS ALONG
THE BORDER IF NEED BE
ACCORDING TO THOSE FAMILIAR
WITH THE PLANNING, BRET?